CHARLIE KIRK, THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS, GODSPEED.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IS NOT GETTING A
LOT OF ATTENTION IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE DON'T GIVE CANADA ANY
ATTENTION AT ALL BUT ALL OF A
SUDDEN CANADA LOOKS LIKE THE
SOVIET UNION.
SEEM LIKE WE ARE EXAGGERATING A
LITTLE BIT?
WELL, THEY ARE BURNING CATHOLIC
AND ANGLICAN CHURCHES IN RECENT
DAYS, LEFTIST GROUPS ARE
APPROVED.
CANADA'S LEADERS ARE CONDEMNING
THE BURNING OF CHURCHES, NO,
THEY ARE ENDORSING THE BURNING
OF CHURCHES.
THE HEAD OF THE BRITISH COLUMBIA
CIVIL LIBERTY ASSOCIATION, A
MONSTER, TWEETED THIS.
"BURN IT ALL DOWN."
THEN A CLOSE CONFIDANT OF THE
PRIME MINISTER OF CANADA,
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, A MAN CALLED
GERALD, CALLED THE ARSON, AND WE
ARE QUOTING NOW,
"UNDERSTANDABLE."
A WOMAN CALLED HEIDI MATTHEWS OF
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL DESCRIBED THE
ATTACKS AS "THE RIGHT OF
RESISTANCE TO SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICE, BURNING CHURCHES.
NOW.
THIS IS NOT THE SPAN OF THE
CIVIL WAR, THIS IS NOW IN
CANADA.
THEY JUST TORE DOWN THE STATUE
OF QUEEN VICTORIA IN WINNIPEG ON
CANADA DAY.
>> NO PRIDE IN!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: WOULD LOVE TO GO
INSIDE CANADA TONIGHT BUT WE
CAN'T GET THERE, IT'S LIKE 1985
ALBANIA, IT'S A CLOSED COUNTRY,
SO INSTEAD WE ARE SPEAKING BY
SETTLE IT TONIGHT WITH REBEL
MEDIA WITHIN CANADA, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR DOING THE SHOW, WHAT IS
GOING ON IN CANADA?
SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS -- IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> I'M RELUCTANT TO USE THE WORD
KRISTALLNACHT BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
THERE YET.
THAT WAS THE NIGHT OF THE BROKEN
GLASS IN PREHOLOCAUST GERMANY
WHERE THEY SMASHED AND BURNED
AND KILLED JEWISH SYNAGOGUES.
IT WAS A PRECURSOR TO THE
HOLOCAUST.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE NOT THAT FAR
GONE YET BUT WHAT YOU CALL IT
WHEN LITERALLY DOZENS OF
CHURCHES ARE BEING
SYSTEMATICALLY VANDALIZED,
TORCHED?
THERE WAS ONE FIRE IN THE BC
INTERIOR THAT WIPED OUT ALL
VILLAGE OF -- TWO PEOPLE DEAD
AND IT IS NOT YET DETERMINED WHO
CAUSED IT, BUT IT WAS IN AN AREA
WHERE OTHER CHURCHES HAVE BEEN
TORCHED, SO IT MAY ACTUALLY HAVE
ITS FIRST VICTIMS.
THE CRAZY THING IS THIS IS SO
EXPLICITLY AND ANTICHURCH
HATE CRIME WAVE AND YET
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, WHO IS NORMALLY
THE FIRST AND THE WOKEST, WAITED
A WEEK BEFORE SAYING ANYTHING
AND HE LITERALLY SAID THAT'S NOT
THE WAY TO GO.
THAT WAS AS TOUGH AS HE GOT.
HE INTRODUCED AN
ANTI-HATE CRIMES BILL IN
PARLIAMENT THAT'S TARGETING MEAN
TWEETS AND FACEBOOK POSTS, BUT
LITERALLY YOU HAVE CHURCH AFTER
CHURCH BEING TORCHED BY
ANTIFA-STYLE TERRORISTS AND HE'S
ALMOST SILENT ON THE MATTER AND
HIS RIGHT-HAND MAN FINDS IT
UNDERSTANDABLE.
I THINK THESE ARE DARK DAYS FOR
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM IN CANADA.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE BURNING
CHURCHES AND THE HEAD OF THE BC
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMISSION SAYS
BURN IT ALL DOWN?
I MEAN, THAT PERSON SOUNDS LIKE
A DANGEROUS LUNATIC.
WHO IS THAT?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> AND SHE HASN'T BEEN SACKED.
THAT WAS OVER A WEEK AGO THAT
SHE SAID IT.
IN FACT, VARIOUS BOARD MEMBERS
OF HER CIVIL LIBERTIES
ASSOCIATION HAVE SUPPORTED HER.
BY THE WAY, THESE CHURCHES OFTEN
HAVE ABORIGINAL, INDIGENOUS
CONGREGANTS AND THEY ARE SAYING
DON'T BURN OUR CHURCHES DOWN.
IT'S THE CANADIAN EQUIVALENT OF
ONE BLACK LIVES MATTER BURNS
DOWN BLACK-OWNED BUSINESSES IN
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT DOES NOT HELP BLACK PEOPLE.
IN CANADA, MOST OF THESE
CHURCHES ARE ABORIGINAL-FOCUSED
AND YOU OFTEN HAVE, IN ONE CASE,
WHITE ANTIFA-STYLE VANDALS WERE
FILMING THEMSELVES DESECRATING A
CHURCH AND FROM THE VERY TOP
IT'S EITHER SILENCE OR TACIT
SUPPORT.
>> Tucker: I'M ASHAMED TO SAY
THE AMERICAN CHRISTIAN LEADERS
HAVE MOSTLY BEEN SILENT ABOUT IT
TOO AND I WISH THEY WOULDN'T BE.
AS WERE, I APPRECIATE THAT
REPORT FROM CANADA, I HOPE
SOMETIME TO BE ABLE TO VIS